when the government was chasing me I
wanted to get a sense of how close they
were and to me this was a game you know
it was like kind of like I was a little
bit insane and I treated my fugitive
status as like big video game
unfortunately had real consequences and
I why I did this psychologically as I
loved putting myself in dangerous
situations and then trying to work my
way out of them now I don't know what
why I like doing this but I did so what
I did is I hacked into the cellular
provider in Los Angeles that that
serviced the FB i-- cell phones numbers
of the agents that were chasing me so to
make a long story short I was able to
get the cell phone numbers of the agents
and then by hacking into the cellular
provider I could monitor where they
physically were you know physically in
Los Angeles I could also monitor who
they were calling and who was calling
them so based on my traffic analysis and
my location data I was able to find out
at the feds ever got close and in one
time they did I had an early warning
system set up in 1992 when I was working
as a private investigator in Los Angeles
and when the warning system was tripped
off I found out that the FBI was
actually at my apartment and I was a
mile away in Calabasas but I just I just
drove in from the apartment to look to
work so obviously they weren't there to
arrest me and I didn't think that they
were still near my apartment that it was
to surveil me so the only that logical
thing is that they were there to conduct
a search and that means to get a search
warrant they didn't have a search
warrant yet so in in every you know
criminal case when they have to get a
search warrant from a judge they have to
write down the precise description the
premises to be searched
it's the Fourth Amendment stuff and so I
figured out that that was going on and
so the very next day I cleaned up air
well that evening I cleaned up
everything from my apartment that the
FBI may be interested in and then the
very next day I went out to Winchell's
donuts and got a big adored a dozen
assorted donuts and I labeled the box
FBI donuts and I put in the refrigerator
so when they so when they were going to
come search the only thing they would
find is I had some donuts for
they search the next day they then find
anything I don't even know if they open
the refrigerator but if they did they
didn't help themselves to a donut for
some reason I don't know why